tout d'abord la tenue de nuit l'oréal 1
qu'elle a vraiment chez elle de nadège
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christophe carrière
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok c'est ma fille s'est fait un carton
en battant c'est vraiment le genre de
tenues que vous mettez le soir pour
dormir
oui non pas la gemmi le tee shirt de
soirée parce que voilà d'habitude ce
t-shirt là je ne mets pas tout le temps
parce qu'il n'est pas vous avez raison
c'est des choses qu'on peut pas pour le
bolliger hama et authentique c'est vrai
c'est que c'est pas sexy et risquer la
nuit tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci bonjour je m'attendais je ne vous
le cache pas un truc un peu plus
affriolants sa lé confort ses propos les
chaussures maman des vosges assez les
chaussons vosgien donc de laine de
mouton je sais ma grand mère
c'est peut-être bientôt qu'il va falloir
aller coucher les enfants on parlait
tout à l'heure de plus belle la vie à
côté c'est du pipi de chat
car voici isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais attendez isabelle errot tour mais
avec ça le soir vous êtes comme ça chez
vous un jeu bourrin culotte
oui mais j'avais quand même pas venir en
culotte infliger ça aux enfants ont
presque enfants attention spectacle
american mister gros tuyaux
[Applaudissements]
cette seule cette scène je vous dire
c'est du fellini
mais pourquoi le besco base le ti priori
pas ce qu'il a dit tout à l'heure qui
quand le sort de mes gros tuyaux mais
vous imaginez que ce type est directeur
des magazines de presse il arrive comme
ça en se faisant avec le public hurle
groothuis comment tuer mais le show au
mont d'or carole et les turbines
[Applaudissements]
là
tiens
[Applaudissements]
voyez vous pourriez vous battre
l'annoncé je suis même coeur prendre le
pari vous la mettez là il y avait rien
pendant 45 minutes à bien la courbe
d'audience mais regardez là
souple et c'est hugh hefner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la matière la chambre à coucher pour
jean-michel c'est son bureau donc il a
fallu travailler là c'est pour les
castings
c'est hugh hefner le patron de playboy
72 on signe de respect pour ma personne
[Applaudissements]